hello everyone I've already shown you
one wild game today so I thought why not
another and which chess player better
and for this occasion then make hell
tile and this game was played in 1971 it
was played in Estonia in Tallinn hence
the name of the game Talon Talon and me
cos I was playing against the Estonian
Grandmaster Andres Farina and this game
is well it's not only complicated it's
well it definitely deserves an applause
at least so let's see this game we have
a four by tau and c5 this silly event
Knight to f3 d6 d4 C capture Sundy for a
nightcap verson d4 and now Knight to c6
the diamond on variation and Knight to
c3 and now Queen to c7 the bastard
covariation of the time out of Bishop to
e3 a6 Bishop to d3 nice to f6 and star
castles and we have Bishop to d6 and if
you look at this position okay black
this is retina to capture the pawn on h2
would check and well the usual move here
would be g3 or maybe even h3 but style
already starts playing for the crowd and
you go stink to h1 saying sure grab my
h2 pawn but you will not grab it with
tempo but black of course doesn't
capture it this doesn't really achieve
anything he plays a stronger move he
plays h5 we have f4 bye-bye towel and
now Knight to g4 threatening this well
Bishop and e3 I'm also kind of provoking
tile to play h3 but of course Allison's
interest is in this we have Queen to f3
and now black captures this dark square
Bishop Knight chapter 73 and Queen
captures and e3 and it's interesting
here that okay black does have a bishop
there but he like just the spent I mean
he spent 3 moves with this 992 or 694
and 93 and that was a pretty good night
especially well while the knight was in
g4 and after trading this night he is
left with this Bishop and c8 which is
well far from far from developed so we
have Queen to b6 now pinning the screen
here since the Queen only three
unprotected and top late-night c2e2 now
adding protection to the sb4 night
we have e5 and okay the night is detect
F captures on e5 is possible but the
best move here would probably be nice to
f5 I'm pinning and also protecting the
Queen
but again towel plays for the crowd as
tall as death roar of the crowd and he
plays Queen to g3 Tao hangs a piece here
and it's a threatening Queen to g7 and
okay why not
I mean this is good for black and black
captures a knight he captures on d4 and
e4 and Queen captures on g7 threatening
that rook on h8 and we have a rope to f8
top ways 'if I've now taking that Bishop
to Bishop to e7 and of course Cal pushes
f5 and this is well this is a classic
position when you play against all you
start seeing ghost and black black is
actually okay in this position and
simply capturing the pawn and b2 would
be what sufficient to continue the game
but black starts defending against the
threats that aren't that they simply
aren't there for example f6 looks too
dangerous but it's really not and black
plays f6 himself to stop this and this
is the well this is a feeding tell
exactly what he wants and he plays a
nice step for and well what is the idea
of Knight f4 you will see black plays
Queen rook to f7 attacking the Queen and
here we have a vintage town move he
plays he captures on f6 now offering
offering his Queen to black and let's
see what what happens is the Queen get
sacrifice is accepted if route casters
on g7 then ask after sin g7 threatening
point to g8 Queen Queen King to f7 and
I'll f6 with an attack on this Bishop
Bishop captures on f6 and now nice to d5
with an attack on the Queen and also
attacking this Bishop twice so after the
Queen moves Queen to a5 rook to f6 check
kink captures on g7
rook to g6 check King to a trade
rook 286 checks King to g8 and now rook
captures on h5 and well the three
of course nice to have six checked would
a discovery on the Queen here and black
decided not to go into this he doesn't
win a queen but again I mean look at
this powerful bishop on c8 so after it
captures an f6 a black plays Knight to
e5 and table is Bishop to c4 simply
Queen to h8 here was sufficient for
white but again it all goes at a place
for the crowd he plays Bishop to c4 and
now threatening to capture the rook here
and again tall is offering a full piece
so black accepts this tonight casters on
c4 which is the best move for black and
table is Queen to g8 we have Bishop to
f8 in the pending from checked and now
it's always nice to h5 we have nice to
d6 look lo que te 1 with check King to
d8 and now a beautiful move by tal he
plays rook to d7 and well this right is
pretty obvious he's threatening to
capture this rook and f7 and if if if
Blanc decided to capture this rock with
rook captures on on on e7 he would get F
captors 97 would check in captures on e7
Queen to g5 check now bringing the king
to the Kings side King to f7 a Queen to
f6 check King to e8 and out rook to e1
and well the mate will soon follow
so after this move rook to e7 his
opponent played a queen to b5 and now
how plays rook to e1 because okay the
Queen was not attacking this rook
he wanted to well he offered tell his
rook in exchange for this mess checkmate
on f1 so Tom simply plays rook F to e 1
and I'll Queen to d5 so okay this was a
pretty solid maneuver going to b5 - d5
now protecting that f7 rook but stop
ways Knight to f4 now with an attack on
the Queen and the black captures Queen
captures on a 2 and this move isn't the
capture a pawn it's just a - oh there
there are no other squares for the Queen
to be on since the Queen has to protect
this rook on f7 and here at all finishes
the game
with another brilliant style move he
plays ignite the e6
and if you look at this position I mean
this this diagram exactly I mean it's
it's it's so disgusting it's even hard
to look at it but it is again it's
beautiful and let's see what happens if
a black would capture this night if D
captures an e6 then rook captures on f7
Knight captures on s7 and Queen captures
and I fate with check King to c7 now
Queen captures on f7 was checked in to
b6 and I'll simply add captures on e6
and well these pawns are a lot more I
mean they worked a lot more than this
Bishop and rook combined
so after this night the e6 move by tau
his opponent was probably already sick
of playing this game and he decided not
to go for this but to go for Queen
captures on e6 so top with F captures on
e6 we have worked to f6 and now towel
and the game instantly would work the f7
threatening well to capture the bishop
if if rogue captures for example I don't
know if the rook is captured with wood
nice captors on f7 then simply e7 check
and well this is all over
for example King c7 and Todd gets
another Queen
but after route to f7 his opponent was
probably probably even glad to resign
this game so yeah a beautiful game by
style and there definitely a wild one
and one of the more complicated games
played by towel I've seen and I've seen
a lot of them so yeah that's it for this
video thank you all for watching as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and I'll see you soon